the retrial of a group of men who
attacked and killed american bakari
henderson while he was visiting greece
has been delayed again
we expected it to begin this morning the
attack was captured on camera and we
must warn you the video is upsetting the
22 year old was beaten to death by a mob
outside a bar in 2017. the next year
nine of the attackers went on trial six
were found guilty of deadly assault but
none was convicted of murder a
prosecutor felt the sentences were too
lenient and seven men went back to court
this morning mts taeb is following the
latest developments mts good morning
nate everyone good morning well already
we've learned that one of the defendants
a greek barman has been acquitted but
the remaining defendants all of them
serbian descent will be back in court on
march 11 as bakari henderson's family
continues their fight for justice
bakari henderson's love for life was as
deep as his wanderlust at just 22 years
old the recent college graduate had
already traveled the world but it was on
a night out on the greek island of
zakinthos that his adventurous spirit
was brutally cut short
the woman seen in this surveillance
video told police she asked to take a
selfie with henderson when a man
standing nearby said there are a lot of
serbians in the bar why are you talking
to a black guy
what happened next saw henderson punched
attacked by a mob and 30 seconds later
he was dead
in 2018 none of the alleged attackers
all of serbian descent were convicted of
murdering henderson and just six were
found guilty of the far lesser charge of
deadly assault since then at least four
have already been released
speaking outside a greek court this week
henderson's parents said a retrial
needed to happen we decided
that the first decision was not fair
we felt that they should have been
charged with murder
something the original prosecutor agreed
with because greece doesn't have double
jeopardy laws a retrial was ordered and
is now being watched closely by the
highest reaches of the greek and
american governments
now cbs news has learned vice president
kamala harris has taken what's been
described as a quote personal interest
in the retrial of bakari henderson's
alleged killers and even discussed the
case with the greek prime minister while
at the munich security conference last
week where she was told he'd personally
keep her informed dana
akari henderson's family a mod arbury's
family is a parent you can only imagine
what they go through mts taeyab in
london thank you